The following
content is provided
by MIT OpenCourseWare under
a Creative Commons license.
Additional information
about our license
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general
is available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
I'll start with this.
This is a method for a
particular class of problem
and maybe moving
interfaces, moving curves,
curves that are -- or
surfaces, in higher dimensions,
that are being transported, and
it's their shape that matters.
So it's a sort of topic within
shape differential equations
rather than particle
differential equations.
And some cases of
this problem can
be studied by a
particularly fast method,
developed here at
MIT in Course 6
actually, called the
fast marching method.
It's really thanks
to Per-Olof Persson
that there's now quite a
bit on the 18.086 web page.
The basic equations that'll
be in the lecture and also
demonstrations, quick
demos that show the point.
And I better mention Sethian
and Osher, who jointly proposed
the method, conceived of this
approach in the late '80s,
and each has written a
book, or coauthored a book,
on the level set method.
So those books are, so to speak,
the authorities on the method.
OK, so what's the idea?
Well, here is the
curve, the shape,
the interface that's moving.
And let's suppose -- well,
imagine it's sort of --
there's a wall pf fire here,
and think of it as a moving fire
front.
Then that fire front will
move, normal to itself,
to some later
position at time 1.
We could normalize -- in
a perfect case when it was
homogeneous and the speed of
movement didn't change with
position, we could imagine
that the speed is 1.
So where is this fire
front here at time 1?
It contains all
the points that are
reached from the initial
fire in unit time.
And since we're
going at speed 1,
let's say, this is all
the points at distance 1.
This curve, in this
best, simplest case,
will be the curve
that's everywhere
a distance 1 away
from this curve.
Now, how to describe the
curves is the key point here.
Shall I describe the
curve by particles?
I could imagine
these points as being
my unknowns, my positions, and
some equation for following
them.
So I follow those -- ordinary
differential equations,
one for every point -- and they
reach new positions at time 1.
And then I interpolate the next
curve, the new curve at time 1.
Well, that's not what we do.
That's not the idea of
the level set method,
and I'll explain why that
idea of following particles,
which is a totally natural one,
comes to grief, numerically,
too often.
This picture, of course,
was like an ideal case,
and the particles separated a
little bit, but not too much.
Just to say in a word, the
trouble with the particle idea
is that particles
could separate wildly,
so you had a big, big gap
to fill in, like a fan.
Or they could come very close
together so that you had
total instability numerically.
You couldn't compute
any differences
because the distance
was too small,
and that would be like a shock.
So we're really connecting
this type of problem.
It connects well with
the conservation laws
that we've been studying.
Fans and shocks appear, and
I'll show you right away.
Can I just say, what
is the approach?
What does this word
"level set" mean?
Well, the level set
of a function --
I'm saying what this
word level set is,
and that's going to be the
way the curve is described,
sort of implicitly.
Instead of saying
where the points are
that are on the
curve, the curve is
being given by an equation
like phi of x, y equals 0,
or phi of x, y equal 1,
or phi of x, y equals 7.
Those three curves would
be level sets of phi.
Do you see the idea
of levels sets?
They're the solutions
to the equation
phi of x, y equal constant.
Let me take a simple example
here on the board that I can --
so the idea of level
sets, first of all.
Let me take an easy -- a
particularly nice function.
phi of x, y equals, say,
x squared plus y squared.
OK, so I want to ask,
what are the level
sets of that function?
So I set phi of x, y equals a
constant, to get the c level
set, you could say.
And, of course,
we recognize that
as a circle when c is
positive, and there
is no set when c is negative.
So this would be -- the
level sets would be circles.
So that would be
one description.
I mean, what we're
really doing is
we're introducing a new
dimension to the problem.
Here, it's a 2D problem
with x square and y squared,
but I'm bringing in
the third dimension, z,
and thinking of the curve in
the xy-plane as being produced
by -- so what would be the graph
of z equals x squared plus y
squared?
That's some surface now in 3D.
So I have x, y, and now I've
introduced this third dimension
in order to see a whole surface.
And now I cut that surface
by the plane z equal to c.
So z equal to c cuts through
that surface by a plane here.
And that cuts out
a circle, which
I can drop down to the xy-plane
if I want to see it down there,
and that's the level
set at height c.
So that's a way to describe
the curve, but it's sort of --
it's implicit.
You'll see that it has
major advantages when --
maybe I can just describe
them without drawing them.
Suppose I have a
problem with two fires,
say, two circles
of fire, spreading.
What's going to happen,
as time evolves,
with these two circles of fire?
Well, having taken circles,
they're just going to expand,
so after a little time,
I've got two bigger circles.
But after a little
more time, the circles
will meet and form
one non-circle, right?
A sort of figure-eight shape.
Now that's a change in
topology, and the world
of shape calculations
is always having
to ask, how am I going to
deal with changes in topology
when curves meet, when
unconnected things become
connected, or when
connected things disconnect?
And the one great value
of the level set approach
is it deals with that easily.
I could imagine a double -- so
I don't know that I'll succeed
to do it here, but I could
imagine a function, which --
OK, maybe this example,
this picture, isn't too bad.
So that's intended
to be a surface.
Well, let me make the
surface go up that way.
OK, so when I cut
it at z equals c,
that might cut the surface
in two different planes.
So the level set at a
certain level is two circles.
There's two circles.
But now, let z increase,
and what happens?
You see how naturally,
as z increases,
these two circles are
coming closer and closer,
and at a certain
point, they merge.
And phi of x and y remains
a totally nice function.
I mean, I could create some
probably fourth-degree function
curve that would do that fine.
I could graph it.
I could visualize it.
And the point is that by
going up that one dimension
and then slicing at
different levels,
you allow these things
to happen smoothly.
OK, so that's one feature of
level sets, that description.
OK, so that's the way curves
are going to be defined.
So our unknown
becomes this function,
which will become a
function of x, y, and t
with some initial condition.
OK, so now, let me
evolve the curve.
Well, OK, yeah, let
me evolve a curve.
So we already took the case
of a circle, which just grows,
and that's a piece of it.
Let me do a couple more
example so that you see --
how does a corner evolve?
Suppose that's at t equals
0, we have a corner.
We have sort of a fire in
here, and it's growing outward.
And we're looking for all
the points at distance 1
from this curve.
This is our curve at time 0.
OK, what do the points
look like at time 1?
Well, these points here
will certainly be a distance
1 away from our curve.
These points here will be a
distance 1 away from our curve.
But then there's a little
circular arc, right --
maybe I should make
that dashed line, too --
which are additional
points at distance 1.
So in this case, the evolving
curve has smoothed out.
That corner, which we might
describe as a jump in the slope
if we were thinking about jumps
from the last week's topic,
has -- well, I guess
I'd use the word fan.
That jump in slope has -- sort
of the characteristics or some
key lines here, and here was an
area where none of these lines
are matching, but we
have distance 1 still.
Somehow, the equation is --
the slope is becoming smooth,
which it wasn't initially.
Now the opposite
could also happen.
A corner could appear
from a smooth start.
So that would correspond,
of course, in our thinking.
We immediately
think, oh, we started
with something smooth,
evolved for a little while,
and a shock appeared.
So a shock would
correspond to the --
it's a shock in the
slope, so to speak.
So the curve itself
will be continuous.
Let me take it -- well, let
me just take it straight.
I mean -- oops!
Well, I was hoping
to make it tangent,
so let me make it more obviously
tangent, so a little --
maybe an arc of a
circle or something,
and then straight again, just
as a model that you can see
what's happening.
OK, what will happen now?
So that's again t equals 0.
So that, you see, has
-- these are now --
the fire is moving
normal to the surface,
normal to the fire front.
And you see what happens now
is, after a certain time,
say t equal to 1, we're going
to have a corner appear.
This'll get steeper and steeper.
The slope will change
faster and faster.
Here it takes a little while
to change from that slope.
It curves around and
slowly gets to that slope.
But that is going to get
squeezed in as we move forward
in time and -- well, it's
essentially time running
in the opposite
direction from this box.
So this would be at t
equal to 1, with a corner.
OK, and maybe those examples
will explain why the idea
of a particle method isn't great
because if we put particles --
I'll just say that again.
If we tried to
follow this, which
would be a completely
natural idea in discretizing
the differential problem, would
be to follow particles there.
They travel perpendicular
to the fire.
They reach here and here,
but nobody reaches there,
so we don't have any
information there.
And if we did try the
particle method here,
we'd have a bunch of particles
that start following the law
of moving -- well, we have to
figure out where the tangent
direction is, and perpendicular
to that is the normal
direction.
The particles move
along, and you
see that all these
particles are going
to be really close together
after a little time,
and then there, they meet.
So the particle method
just basically fails
on a problem like this.
On a problem that stays
beautiful and smooth and keeps
it shape, probably
the particle --
the following ordinary
differential equation for each
particle and then interpolating
to find a curve is reasonable.
But level set method
is a different way.
OK, so let me stay with the
level set idea, which involves,
of course, remembering if
this is the curve phi of x, y
equals 0, then the
normal direction
is the same direction
as the gradient.
I mean, that's the
one bit of calculus
that we absolutely need, is
that the gradient of a function
points in the normal direction.
And if we want a unit vector
n, the unit normal vector,
we have to divide by its length.
So that's the basic formula
from calculus of two variables.
And then there's a
special case of a function
when the gradient is 1.
So we have -- that
formula simplifies
because the denominator is
just a 1 for these functions.
OK, so these are
distance functions.
Functions with
gradient everywhere 1
are kind of special and
nice, very special and nice.
And I guess that
if everything is --
so I spoke about
distance function here.
So I allowed myself to take --
to imagine that the function
phi was the distance, that
everything was traveling with
speed F equal 1.
So let me introduce that
letter F for the speed,
and in this case, it's 1.
So at time t -- the function
that gives the distance has
gradient 1.
Maybe an example would serve.
Let me go back to
this circle here.
OK, suppose these are my -- I'm
not doing this tricky case with
two circles, but just
back to a single circle.
So if I take the gradient
of that function, I get --
it's a vector, right?
The x-derivative and then the
y-derivative, it's 2x and 2y.
And that's a vector
with some magnitude.
Probably the
magnitude is about 2r,
the distance from the center.
It's not 1.
This is not a distance function.
The distance function that
has the same level curves
but has gradient
equal 1 would just
be the square root of x
squared plus y squared.
That's a distance.
OK, so that distance
function -- say,
and let me measure
distance from the center.
OK, so the distance
from the origin
is 0, when x and y are 0.
I claim that this
distance function is --
that that function is this
perfect kind for the level set
method where its level sets
are still those same circles,
but the gradient of that
thing, the gradient of this --
of course, this is just r.
And the gradient of it, if I
take the x-derivative of this
-- so let me take the
gradient of the distance,
just in case you were really
remembering what we easily
mastered in calculus
of several variables.
The x-derivative of
that is, well, I get 2x,
and then I get a half
from the square root,
and then the square root
goes in the denominator.
So that's just x over r, x over
the square root, if you like.
x over the square root
is the first component.
That's the x-derivative.
The y-derivative of this
is 2y from the chain rule,
and then the whole square
root produces 1/2 square root
to the -- square root
in the denominator.
In other words, it produces
y over the square root.
And sure enough -- so that's
the gradient and sure enough,
if I take its magnitude, I take
this squared plus this squared,
square root, but I get 1.
OK, so distance functions
are the good ones.
So in working with
the level set method,
we will follow equations,
numerically, of course,
and phi of x and y
might start out --
phi of x and y and 0 might
be a distance function,
but later on in time
after we've followed phi,
it probably changes from
a distance function.
And if it changes a lot, if its
gradient is getting out of hand
-- for example, the gradient
of this is getting bigger.
And after a while, we can
stop, reinitialize to make
the gradient 1 again.
Effectively, we would come back
to this function and proceed.
So this reinitialization is part
of the numerical computation
that I won't say more about.
Really what I now have to do
is say what's the key equation?
What's the equation that we
solve numerically in x, y, t?
Remember, it's going to be a
partial differential equation.
OK, so first we
have to know what's
the rule for the
evolution of a curve.
So this decides the
movement of the curve.
This decides the movement
of the curve, this velocity
vector, velocity field,
velocity vector, v, (v_1, v_2).
It's a vector.
All right, then
the neat thing is
that we get, by using this level
set description of the curve,
to this equation.
The convection
equation, you could say.
It's like our one-way
wave equation.
If v is a constant,
it's just our equation,
but now we're in
two space dimensions
instead, where before,
we were just in one.
But if v is not a constant,
then, for example,
v may depend on phi.
The velocity might
depend, and it often
does depend on the curvature of
phi in some nonlinear problem,
then our equation
becomes nonlinear,
but it still has a nice form.
So that expresses exactly what
our thinking is that the level
sets -- that the function,
the evolution of the function,
tells us how the level sets
evolve, and then, at any time,
we read off the position of
the curve from the level set.
And then one more
step to that equation,
which is often easier
computationally than this one.
So I'm going to take a
simple step between there
and there in the case when v
is in the normal direction.
So let me look at
this v dot grad phi
that came into the
convection equation.
I'll divide and multiply by
the magnitude of the gradient,
and then I recognize this
as the normal vector.
I recognize that as n.
So this is v dot n, and I'm
going to give a name to v dot n
and call it F. That's the speed,
speed in the normal direction,
v dot n.
And then there's
this factor magnitude
of grad phi coming along.
OK, so that's the equation.
That's sort of the
famous level set equation
where, if F is a
constant, that's the case
we're speaking about
of a fire moving.
But if F depends on the --
F could be a function of --
if I put parentheses in there, F
could be a function of gradient
phi, a more
complicated function.
For example, I wrote down,
because I would otherwise
forget, this could be our --
this is a possible F of grad
phi.
Actually, it depends on
more than the magnitude
so I'd better -- yeah.
And certainly not a linear one
because of that denominator.
So a big set of examples in
this subject, not linear,
are curvature shapes.
Actually, the curvature
problem is quite interesting.
If the movement depends
on the curvature --
so suppose I start with an
elliptical-looking shape,
the curvature is
smaller here, right?
Oh, I'm sorry, smaller curvature
there, larger curvature there,
and if we choose
the right evolution,
often it will come -- maybe this
is a case where the movement is
inward because the curvature is
somehow the appropriate vectors
pointing in.
Here it would move in slowly
because the curvature is small.
Here it would move in faster
because the curvature is
larger.
The curvature is
tending to even out.
And, in fact, after a certain
-- as time goes on, any shape
approaches a circle, and the
circle shrinks and shrinks
and disappears.
So that this class of --
this sort of nonlinear group
of problems has a nice
geometric picture,
that whatever shape
you begin with,
you could even begin with
a really weird shape like
a barbell or something.
So this has zero curvature.
It wouldn't move at the start.
This would move in, so
after a little while
it would be like this, then
the corner would move in.
So it seems a little unlikely
it's true that after a while,
the shape would become
nearly circular,
get smaller and smaller,
and the shape would vanish.
Anyway, that a
curvature problem.
OK, so I guess following
the main theme of the course
would be write down a finite
difference method for the level
set equation.
That's the natural thing to do.
Write down a finite
difference method
for the level set equation.
Solve that numerically.
So that would be
on the web page.
The difference
equation is going to be
a sort of upwind
equation, but it's
a little messier
in two variables
to write out in detail here.
You'll see it there on the web.
OK, so you solve it,
and proceed in time,
and reinitialize when necessary
or when it seems advisable,
and you get a great
picture of this evolving,
moving interface.
So problems of that kind.
Or optimizing the interface.
There are other problems
where you might --
ones on the web where--
you might be, look,
the unknown might be a shape.
And you're looking
for the shape that
maybe makes an eigenvalue as
small as possible, subject
to some constraint.
So problems for shapes.
That's really the
type of problem
that level set methods
are created for.
OK, and these example show
the connection -- actually,
somehow the -- yeah, it's really
that if I tried to connect it
to conservation laws, to
the previous lectures,
this is our earlier guy,
would be -- in one variable,
let's say, this would correspond
to the derivative of maybe phi
or capital U. So the
conservation laws for little u
correspond to equations
like this for phi.
Well, or really, grad
phi in more dimensions.
OK, well, all right.
So what else remains to
say about this topic?
Really, I guess my main
point is to introduce you
to the idea of level sets
and level set method for when
problems of moving interfaces
and shape optimization come up.
I guess I also wanted
to say something
about this fast marching method.
OK, so what's that?
That's a case where there's
a very fast solution
to this problem.
And that case occurs when
the wave front is always
moving the same way, when
the F holds its sign.
So it would apply here.
So I could use the
fast marching method.
Rather than the
level set equation
and a finite difference
method for it,
I could use a fast marching
method for this problem
because I have no danger
of the shape turning,
changing direction,
coming back in on itself,
all the crazy things
that can happen,
the things that are
illustrated on the web.
OK, so the fast marching
method, well, maybe I --
so what's the problem
in that nice case?
I want to find -- I
could put on a mesh.
Yeah, let me take as a problem
the computation of the distance
function from this curve.
OK, so I could create a mesh.
So I'm going to take that
problem and turn it into a --
discretize it in a natural
way, and I'm searching
for the distance function.
So d of x and y is the distance
that I now want to compute.
It's the distance
from the curve C.
And let me make it a
signed distance function
so I'll make d negative in
here and positive outside
of the curve.
OK.
All right, so the
idea is we could --
this fits our level set picture,
but there's a direct way to do
it.
And it's a nice -- it's
an algorithm that computer
scientists probably created
and appreciate, that --
we want to know the distance.
We want to compute d
at the mesh points.
Let me put another mesh point.
OK, so how do I --
so the question is,
how do I get from -- let me
put another y in there, too,
and that created
some more points.
So how to -- what
path -- you know,
how to get the distance from
the curve to each mesh point?
Well, here's the idea,
just in a nutshell.
You keep a list of
tentative distances
to all the mesh
points, and you look
for the one that's closest, like
it's probably maybe that guy.
So maybe that's right
on the curve, let's say.
So the idea is I can
-- that will be --
to get to this point, I'm
never going to take a path that
passes through the others.
To get here, I might
take a path that
goes through an earlier point.
But the nearest point,
the work is done.
So you successively sweep
through the mesh points,
pick the one whose current
distance, tentative distance,
is the smallest, and you
say that is the distance.
That's the right number.
Then now you know how far
it is to get to that point.
So now you could, if you had
to, update all the previous --
all the other distances by
knowing the correct one,
how distant it is, how
distant that point is.
OK, so then that one's settled.
Now you look at your
list, your updated list.
You pick the smallest one in
that, the closest one in that.
You found the best way
because things are never
going to reverse in
sign; you're never
going to travel
out and come back.
So the closest
one, you've got it.
So that might be
this or something,
and then we would update how
far it takes to get to those.
So that fast marching
method is a, you might say,
fairly natural idea of how
to compute distances when
everything is measured, when our
problem is -- has a fixed sign.
OK, so that's my short comment
on the fast marching method.
My longer comment is on the
level set method and level set
equation, where I
haven't written out
the finite difference
approximation that people
typically use, and
note on the web.
All right, so that's level
sets, which I probably
will not come back to.
It's kind of a one-shot lecture.
So let me take
the remaining time
to get feedback on the homework.
So were there four problems,
possible candidate problems,
for homework?
Let me put those down again.
I'm just going to ask first,
who did which problem.
So the first problem was
the conservation law -- no,
was the one-way-- OK, remind me.
I don't remember
the order I gave.
So was Number 4 the
conservation law?
The nonlinear one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
So the conservation law.
I'll just write down
u_t plus u*u_x equals 0.
Oh yeah, Number 1 was the basic
question of u_t equals c*u_x.
Yeah, that's right.
So that's a very important
and not too obvious
question, a good numerical
question, of what to do.
And Number 2 was the wave
equation; was that right?
AUDIENCE: Schrodinger's.
PROFESSOR:
Schrodinger's, Number 2.
Oh, boy.
OK.
So i*u_xx, which I haven't
discussed in class and I had --
the good question came up, how
do you deal with these complex
numbers because, of course,
it's going to get complex right
away.
Well, one way that
just occurs to me
is take the real
and imaginary parts
so that we get two equations,
two real equations.
PROFESSOR: OK, Number 3
was -- what did I have --
AUDIENCE: The wave equation.
PROFESSOR: Was
the wave equation?
OK, second order?
AUDIENCE: First order.
PROFESSOR: Oh,
first-order wave equation?
Oh, OK.
So what was I -- OK, first-order
wave equation like so.
I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: c*u_x, OK, yep.
All right, so was the question
there to go back to the--
AUDIENCE: Compare.
PROFESSOR: Compare, right.
Compare the methods we've
already established.
And then Number 4 was to tackle
some case of nonlinear equation
where shocks and
fans could appear.
OK, maybe I just get a
sense of who did what.
Number 1 how many?
Wow!
Number 1 was popular and
I think it's justified.
So this is certainly
the biggest choice.
So let me come back and get some
ideas of what you concluded.
Number 2, did anybody
tackle Schrodinger?
Yes.
A couple of complex guys.
Well, I know you asked about it.
Yep, OK, good.
Anybody go back to these?
For this?
You did?
OK, you may have done
a little bit of both.
And did anybody venture
to nonlinear world?
One.
Good, OK.
Nonlinear person.
I'm glad to know that, right.
So this is like -- this homework
you could think of us as like
prep for a possible project.
Your project could grow
out of this homework,
or it could grow from other
things that are coming.
OK.
All right, let's stick with this
one then since a lot of people
will have input on it.
Let me ask -- well, I'll
just ask naive questions
because you've actually
done the calculation.
Is there a method
you'd recommend?
If you had a problem like that
or, I mean, like for real,
and you had to invest
in a code and use it,
just give an opinion.
Or did you only try one method?
Tell me something,
positive or negative,
about your experience with this.
Yeah, thanks.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Maybe you
push -- in theory,
there's some mike you push and
this will be the first time
we've ever done it.
OK, terrific.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Centered explicit.
Let me write that down.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, right.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So, OK, the centered
explicit one
is computing this
from three old values.
We certainly need
three because we've
got a second derivative there.
But then we have
a certain amount
of that second derivative and
a certain amount of this one,
and that can make one of those
three numbers go negative.
They always add the one because
the constant is certainly
a solution we want to keep.
OK, so when a coefficient
went negative,
that doesn't mean
instability; is that right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Fine.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Implicit had
no trouble with that.
Yeah, OK.
Or it didn't matter what the
Peclet number, or the cell
Peclet number was, or
whatever we called it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Uh-huh.
PROFESSOR: I see.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, if you went
-- when you say implicit,
it's just the diffusion
term that's going implicit?
OK, OK.
So that should be a
very stable process,
but, of course, now we've
got this term affecting it.
So you actually found out
that even the implicit one
could break?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Really?
PROFESSOR: Huh!
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Even
the implicit one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah.
So on the implicit part -- so
this was method one and this
was method two, implicit
for the diffusion,
but you found that that
could still be unstable.
OK, yeah.
Anybody else do this comparison?
Can you push your
mike button just to --
this is a hotshot room that
we haven't taken advantage
of, but it's our chance.
AUDIENCE: I actually looked at
the -- when I first did the --
looking at just the
growth factors of explicit
and implicit --
PROFESSOR: OK,
looking at that G --
AUDIENCE: --on the
convection term as well?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I used implicit
for all the diffusion.
And I found the most
stable using upwind,
when both were implicit,
the growth factor
was actually able
to stay below 1.
PROFESSOR: So you moved
the first derivative also
up to the new time?
OK, and that was -- then
you don't have a problem.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
So stable for pretty
much all big R, little r.
But the explicit upwind
for the convection term
was stable for most, as long
as the little r was below 0.5.
PROFESSOR: I see.
So the numbers
could tell you the--
AUDIENCE: Sure.
PROFESSOR: --limits
on little r and big R?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
And then I did the
explicit convection
upwind with the implicit
centered diffusion,
and that seemed to be pretty
stable unless I really started
cranking the numbers out.
PROFESSOR: I see.
Oh, that's the one
that he had also done?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
And now, so I guess I remember,
in the figure that isn't yet
drawn that might emerge
from your calculations,
a possibility where --
depending on the Peclet number,
where it was stable.
It didn't blow up, but
oscillations appeared
and the calculations -- you
wouldn't do it even so --
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's
what you meant, yeah.
OK, so there are cases
where the method isn't good
even though it's stable, which
is like important to realize
that that can happen.
Because up to now, stability has
been, you know, the holy grail.
But it's really a good
solution that's the holy grail.
Yes?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I did kind of a
bigger picture where I basically
tried to build
the pieces so just
to isolate the advection
term and the diffusion term
and then build their matrices.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And then look
at the combination rule.
So when you went to where
you had both terms present--
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: --how the
matrices were actually --
came together to form the--
PROFESSOR: So you took a
matrix picture of the --
with all the mesh points, mesh
values, at once rather than--
AUDIENCE: And then I simulated
with them just convection,
just diffusion and then the
coupled problem of both of them
to see how that -- just
one method may be unstable
for a given formulation--
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: --but yet when
you saw the coupled problem
with those two pieces,
it actually is stable.
So you could look at like the
-- when you build the matrices,
you can look at the eigenvalues
and you can make sure that
they're--
PROFESSOR: Let me
comment a little on that.
I'll do that, but I don't want
to cut off anybody who has
another comment to throw in here
before I say something about --
follow up on matrices.
Anybody got some urgent thing?
Let me just, in the
remaining minute,
just say a word
because, of course,
you'll know that I think
of the matrix description
quickly and fondly.
So just to write down the sort
of matrices that are in here,
from the second difference,
the second difference matrix is
going to be -- it's going
to have our -- well,
I guess it'll be 1, minus
2, and 1 in a typical row.
We haven't written
any matrices down.
It's amazing that -- we'd be
at about the, I don't know,
eighth or ninth lecture now,
and not have seen this matrix,
but here it is.
OK, so that's the matrix where
I'm at a fixed time level.
I'm taking the second
differences of all the points
along that level.
And now, the main
point for the moment
is to contrast that with
a first difference matrix
which, well, that depends
whether I take it centered.
Maybe if it's a
centered difference,
it would be a 1, 0, minus 1.
And, of course, there's a 2
delta x in the denominator.
so a minus 1, 0, 1.
So that would be a
centered difference that
doesn't do anything, doesn't
use the middle value,
but takes the difference
between the value at the right
and the value at the left.
Or, an upwind.
So delta_upwind would be more
of a 1's forward of the point
and minus 1's at
u_(j, n) and 0's here.
OK.
So what you're
saying, am I right
in thinking you took
some combination of the--
AUDIENCE: An implicit method for
one and explicit for the other,
you can do them
independently by --
you can invert the
implicit matrix--
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: --and pre-multiply
the other side and build--
PROFESSOR: So this
is a way to see,
and actually the next
months of our course
are going to be
about, how do you
deal with these large
difference matrices.
These are in one dimension
so they're tridiagonal,
and they're, of course,
easy to deal with it.
But problems, serious problems,
come up in more dimension.
But here, can I just
express one thought here?
The eigenvalues
of these matrices
and their combinations,
as you say,
are what's going to control,
as eigenvalues always do,
growth of solution.
Now we already had
numbers G, growth factors,
that we computed by the von
Neumann idea of following
exponentials, e to the i*k*x.
So these numbers too were --
their purpose was to track
the growth of solution.
And what I want to say is
that very often, I mean,
that these numbers and the
eigenvalues of the matrices,
they're very closely
related ideas.
In fact, they'll
be the same idea
if the eigenvector is
a pure exponential.
So that's really the
link between eigenvalues
of matrices and growth factors
G that depended on frequency k.
If the eigenvector was a pure
e to the i*k*x on the mesh,
then that growth factor is
identical to the eigenvalue
that we get in one step of
the difference equation.
So the idea was that the
eigenvectors, the details
of the eigenvectors,
will be affected
by boundary conditions.
So von Neumann
thought, all right,
I'll cut through that Gordian
knot and just pretend I have
a pure e to the i*k*x.
I look inside the region,
not at the boundary where
we may be doing
something different,
and we get a G, a
growth factor G.
And again, if the eigenfunction
was really an eigenvector, then
that G would be
the same as lambda.
OK, we're past time.
I always appreciate that
you are patient about that.
So I'll collect those
that are complete.
And if you wanted
to speak to Mr. Cho
or have a little more time to
do more, Monday is good, too.
OK, thanks.